good morning John and Merry Christmas so
the last few years I couldn't help but
notice that in the lead-up to Christmas
there is this very strong desire among
some people to try and define exactly
what Christmas is and then complain that
it isn't being done right we're focusing
too much on consumption on the worship
of the acquisition of material things
we're not considering the religious
importance of the holiday not focusing
on the historical roots of the holiday
and all of these traditions are co-opted
from cultures that we kind of helped
destroy Santa is a weird omniscient
magical demigod that clearly anagrams to
Satan in the madness of Christmas Eve
consumerism is indicative of everything
wrong with Western cultures what I think
about all this culture is like light
it's all around us it makes our lives
possible it shows us where to go it
defines how we see things and it helps
us not stub our toes on weird
institutions like the fact that you
shouldn't feed ramen noodles to your
parents when they come visit and women
can wear skirts but men have to put each
individual leg into a separate leg
prison you can't actually see light you
can only see what light hits in the same
way even though culture informs every
bit of our lives it's really difficult
to see holidays and rites of passage are
lenses that focus that cultural light
into forms that we can actually see and
hold and understand and critique and
since Christmas or more broadly like the
holiday giving season is our culture's
biggest holiday it's a time when our
culture is very visible and so too are
all of the bits of our culture that
don't quite jive with our worldview but
unlike a lens that just focuses the
light holidays actually give us an
opportunity to change the nature of the
light change the nature of culture it's
an opportunity to look at what our
society is made of and maybe say I don't
want that bit we can give charitable
contributions instead of gifts we can
focus on the happy wonder of children or
the solstice or Jesus or whatever
tradition feels deepest and richest to
you while doing our very best not to
whine about the fact that other people
are doing it differently because the
things that they value and the culture
that they live in is different from ours
because they're different people for me
this time of year it's friends it's
video games it's Christmas trees it's
Ella Fitzgerald its buddy the else
breathless enthusiasm infecting the
whole world it's cats on Christmas trees
this holiday season whatever you want to
call it has a really deep and diverse
group of traditions to draw on because
our culture is made up a really deep and
diverse group of people
in the end what shines through all of
these traditions is giving one thing to
make the lives of other people richer
and better so that they know that we
care about them and that's a bit of our
culture that I have a hard time having a
problem with John I'll see you on
Tuesday